[Musik]
das podcast ist die blm unique und dann
ein viertel ist das vielleicht weniger
als ein viertel ein viertel ist dann das
also das ist ein problem könnte man
sagen also die studium ist nicht sagen
gemessen die ganze geschichte der
philosophie ist normalerweise die jetzt
gilt philosophie und dann große köpfe
aus der geschichte der philosophie der
größe kopf ist nicht mein kopf sondern
kopf platons oder eines ortes hat jemand
hier ein vorschlag was er oder sie
machen könnte um eine sehr ausführliche
lückenlose darstellung von philosophie
zu erwerben und genießen auf englisch
leider niemand was lautern bitte
danke schön ja ich bin der weiß nicht
was das passende wort dafür dass
herausgeber gastgeber vielleicht
gastgeber in der gastgeber eine podcast
serie namens der hessische verband gab
es dass die website dafür befinden
finden sie auf dem seminarplan das sage
ich auch auf das nächste hier ist die
idee dass ich die wie gesagt die ganze
geschichte der philosophie abdecke jede
woche erscheint eine neue folge
normalerweise sind die folgen
also ich lese von script for also ich
lese vor was das ich geschrieben habe
manchmal gibt es dann interviews mit
anderen experten also andere
professionelle philosophen historiker
und das hat in 2010 angefangen und läuft
immer noch jetzt und wie gesagt
erscheint jede woche jeden sonntag bis
auf sommerpause jedes jahr also ich bin
bei folge 219 oder sowas wie jemand
erraten wie weit ich weggekommen bin mit
diesem jahr 220 folgen frühe mittelalter
also das bestätigt was ich gerade gesagt
habe die die hauptsächlich ist die
geschichte der philosophie antike und
mittelalter das ein bisschen jährige und
ich habe die ganze geschichte der für
das vieh in der islamischen welt
abgedeckt in 70 folgen
und ich habe aber für sie es jetzt
interessant zu wissen dass sich die
ganze antike philosophie schon abgedeckt
haben also dass abgeschlossen
also ich habe alle kritiker abgedeckt
sokrates platon einst ort wie ist
harmlos wie und spätantike flow sowie
einschließlich christliche spätantike
philosophie also wenn sie eine
allgemeine interesse an geschichte der
dieb wird wie haben dann kann ich das
entfernen
natürlich kann ich in diesem kurs nicht
so ausführliches anbieten wie schon
gesagt habe aber ich andererseits werde
ich dann tiefer in manche themen dann
eingehen können und auf deutsch also es
ist nicht überflüssig dass sie die
vorlesungen besuchen wenn sie die fast
keinen nämlich werde ich vor allem es
naheliegend ich werde vor allem platin
und halberstadt ließ besprechen den
vorlesungen bis auch heute und die
letzte sitzung also ich werde heute
antike viel aus wie bis platon
besprechen
das wird schwierig aber nichts durch
wäre wie das was ich in der letzten
sitzung machen muss nämlich nach adlers
nordlys zu besprechen das wird wirklich
sehr gut oberflächlich seien vor allem
weil und das ist nächste praktische
hinweis in der letzten sitzung werden
wir auch einen klausur schreiben also
nicht wir
ich werde es nicht schreiben aber
mag hier von ihnen welche zu schreiben
es ist so gedacht dass diejenigen leute
die kreditpunkte für diesen kurs
brauchen schreiben ein klausur am ende
klar das ist bestanden nicht bestanden
aber das muss ich nachschauen
wenn das für ihren studiengang nicht
passt also wenn sie ein hesse schreiben
oder protokoll oder sowas schreiben
müssen und ich bin immer erstaunt welche
exotische studiengänge dann auftauchen
also ich mache ja ich bin ingenieur und
kunstgeschichte der vor orients und ich
muss eigentlich ein hester ist so
plattform schreiben um solche sachen
was auch immer dann sollen sie einfach
eine e-mail schicken oder nach der
vorlesung mit mir nach der vorlesung
sprechen
wir können aus machen was sie machen
müssen aber im allgemeinen ist es so
gedacht dass die einige leute die
kreditpunkte dafür brauchen ein klausur
schreiben müssen wie viele gibt es die
das machen wollen
mindestens in ihrer das ist es was sie
erwartete erwarten dass sie in klausur
schreiben ja nicken gut blicken es immer
gut also dieses abnicken nichts weil das
ist okay ich glaube das wäre schon alle
praktische sachen hat jemand fragen zur
praktischen themen bevor ich dann in die
philosophie einstürzte
also ich habe 100 gemacht weiß nicht wie
viele leute da sind aber beklagt sie
sind nicht von dort ein wo es in die
hand gibt es noch anders verteilt werden
also ich werde ich werde mehr pläne dann
nächste woche mitbringen
wie viele haben die hand als nicht wahr
aber das sind keine 100 leute die die
hand penny nicht gehoben haben oder
haben manche leute mehr als 1 genommen
und 30 ich werde nächste woche
vielleicht soll ich auch vielleicht
werde ich auch dann nur den seminarplan
sofort auf die website aktualisieren und
dann die andere hand als am ende des
semesters damit sie das schon für
nächste woche haben aber nur zur
kenntnis nächste woche werde ich auch
männern besprechen
ach ja das ist sie haben mich daran
erinnert sie also ich hätte es gern wenn
sie auch ein bisschen im voraus für die
jede vorlesung lesen würden
ich werde nichts nachfragen ob sie das
gemacht haben
aber sie haben wahrscheinlich mehr von
der vorlesung wenn sie einen eintrag
haben wie der text erscheint was da
vorgeht
also ich habe jede jede sitzung der
vorlesung einen relativ kurzen auszug
empfohlen was sie davor lesen können und
für nächste woche werde das minus sogar
bis 18 von platon ja dass zumindest
nicht schlecht weil sich ob sie das
lesen können ironischerweise sind die
die keine händels haben wahrscheinlich
die das mittel nicht lesen können weil
sie so weit weg setzen
das kommt davon so weit weg von dem
lieben lehrenden zu setzen
ok andere fragen sofort sokratische
philosophie hier ist vielleicht die
erste frage inwiefern espresso
kroatische philosophie überhaupt gibt
oder gegeben hat so geläufig zu sagen
dass
all die philosophen die vor plattform
auftauchen die werden normalerweise die
fotografische genannt natürlich sokrates
und jetzt mache ich mein lieblings witz
darüber sollte dieses gekommen und dann
haben die postkarte gewusst dass sie
wirklich probleme hatten ja ok
das team gab englisch vielleicht
das ist dieser ausdruck ist ihre für
forscher kritiker weil michael so
kritikers zins mit sorgt gleichzeitig
also im paddock wie sein ich sage dass
vor allem die art vermissten die sind
eigentlich innerhalb der zeit wo sorgte
schon gelebt hat der da muss man nicht
vergessen dass sorge dies alter mann war
ist er gestorben ist wenn sie ein datum
erinnern wollen dann empfehle ich 399
vor christus das ist soll dieses
todesdatum und dann kann man wissen wer
wann gelebt hat also dass das also
ungefähr 400 haben wir also und
spätestens 399 haben wir schluss mit dem
vorstag artikeln
also das heißt das vor sophie eigentlich
im sechsten und vierten jahrhundert vor
christus stattfindet vielleicht
überraschende weise befinden wir
zunächst nichts in griechenland sondern
in der jetzigen türkei nämlich auf der
küste der ostküste mediterran ische
küste der jetzigen türkei also asia -
wie man das nennen könnte und wir
befinden uns in einer stadt namens
militos und das ist brutal es gelebt hat
und er ist nicht der einzige philosophie
oder vielleicht wissenschaftler ich
werde vielleicht mehr dazu sagen
der in dieser zeit und in mehr oder
weniger in diesem haus gelebt hat wir
haben andere früher vorsichtiger
die auch an der küste der jetzigen
türkei gelebt haben
das ist schon ein beispiel von einer
wichtigen tatsache nämlich dass
griechische philosophie ist dass es
nicht ein phänomen was ausschließlich
mit griechenland zu tun hat natürlich
lebten mehrere wichtige philosophen die
altgriechische schrieben haben
in griechenland selbst und natürlich in
athen wo sorge des platon und hat als
lottes alle gelebt haben und ihre
schulen aufgebaut haben
aber ist es überhaupt nicht der fall das
als sprache nur beschränkt es auf alt
gewesen sein hat griechenland dass das
kann man besuchen mit einer zeitmaschine
ich fahre diesen sondern nach alt
griechenland ist vielmehr war griechisch
sozusagen die lingua franca für den
ganzen mittelmeer von östliche hälfte
des mittelmeers und deswegen ist nicht
so überraschend dass diese philosophen
in der türkei alt griechisch gesprochen
und vielleicht geschrieben haben wobei
eine andere dialekt als in athen
gesprochen wird
die art altgriechisch die sie wie viele
leute hier haben ein bisschen mindestens
ein bisschen griechisch gelernt was sie
gelernt haben ist alles gesagt
es kommt von namen des gebiets athen
sich befindet also sie haben praktisch
hat die athen dialekt altgriechisch
gelernt nichts ironisch aber weiter nach
osten gesprochen würde
also es ist nicht diese seien dessen die
bayerischen hochdeutsch vielleicht weiß
nicht was hochdeutsch da ist und was
beide auf jeden fall das ist immer noch
der fall dann später in der antike also
zum beispiel der spätantike haben wir
einen philosoph wie putin und er
schreibt er es aus ägypten lebt in rom
oder lehrt in rom zeigt aber auf
altgriechisch und das alles im dritten
jahrhundert nach christus
natürlich gibt es auch antike
philosophie in der lateinischen sprache
das fängt eigentlich erst mit cicero an
im ersten jahrhundert vor christus und
nach cisco haben wir weiter der
philosophen die auf lateinisch schreiben
berühmtes beispiel wenn äcker und oft
denkt man okay es gibt diese sogenannte
römisch starker und die schreiben auf
dateien
das ist aber eigentlich falsch also die
drei historiker die man fahren mit der
römischen tradition des tourismus
verbindet sind sänger mark aurel und
appetit und von diesen drei musiker hat
auf latein ausgeschieden
die lateinische für diese situation wird
deutlich größer wenn man christliche
philosophen mit rechnitz zum beispiel
augustinus aber außer diesen organischen
philosophen die auf latein haben der die
lateinische texte geschrieben haben und
dann christliche autor ist antike
philosophie fast ausschließlich auf
welches also das war ein diejenige die
griechisch gelernt
ein gymnasium oder so das war ein guter
grund das zu machen also gut gemacht ok
also wie gesagt mit heißen wir weit
hinten im sechsten jahrhundert vor
christus und hier dass es irgendwie
unnötig aber ich möchte betonen wie weit
weg das ist von uns zeitlich gesehen und
diese das ist immer mein beispiel karl
der große der der kaiser des mit
deutlichen frankreichs ist näher zu uns
in der zeit aus total es carl jarchow
also der erste gestalt in der
mittelalterlichen deutschen geschichte
was sie war schon gelernt haben oder
oder haben sie was vorher wenn man daran
denkt deutsche geschichte mittelalter da
fängt man mit karl der große an oder
gibt es was früher das er ist näher zu
uns als total es in der zeit her
ungefähr in der mitte aber ein bisschen
näher zu uns also das ist sehr lange her
die 26 jahrhundert vor christus und
deswegen könnte man sich gut fragen wie
kann es sein dass er überhaupt wissen
dass diese leute existiert haben
schweigen davon dass wir was über ihre
ideen müssen ist eigentlich erstaunlich
oder man wie viele ist
jahrhundert vor christus leute können
sie nennen
im moment wahrscheinlich 19 im detail
ist hat jemand noch einen vorschlag
und er ist noch ein vorzug rating also
das unterstützt mein punkt danke schön
sind auch verletzend hat jemand eine
stiftung funktioniert bis jetzt war ich
so stolz dass ich daran gedacht habe
eine stift mitzubringen und auch danke
schön sie sind mein held dankeschön
sie wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht
funktionieren
das ist das schönste ex des tages
wunderbar dankeschön zehn offene ist
nichts mit seiner von dem historiker und
student soccer teams zu verwechseln und
jetzt dass ich dabei bin nicht mit
demokratie es der schule platons zu
verwechseln
er ist ein anderer ist sehr viel
vorsichtiger und diese zwei herren sind
philosophen über wenn wir ehrlich gesagt
sehr wenig wissen also bei thales gibt
es vielleicht zwei fragmente die wo wir
eigentlich sicher sind dass die wirklich
von thale stammen mehr oder weniger ich
werde mehr dazu sagen später aber das
wollte ich erklären warum wir überhaupt
was über die diese ganz früher
philosophen wissen und die antwort liegt
in der spätantike also jetzt dass ich
eine funktionierende stift nehmen wir an
dass es jetzt nur antike geschichte also
nicht die ganze weltgeschichte ist und
das antike geschichte und übrigens ab
ich werde jetzt hier nur über
europäische philosophie sprachen
das chinesische oder indische antike für
das vivaz es natürlich auch gibt
vor allem indische philosophie also wenn
man an die spätantike denkt und dann
sogar an die nach spätantike auf
altgriechisch hat man die bis an
tierische tradition hat wo das anfängt
kann man entscheiden aber eigentlich
könnte man denken okay es gibt römisches
imperium und wenn sie dir der westliche
römische reich entfällt oder zerfällt
dann überlebt die östliche hälfte und
das ist die kantine tradition ist
eigentlich nur mehr römische geschichte
und sie haben sich die römer genannt die
biz an tina die haben sich nicht die
byzantiner genannt sondern die römer
aber die haben
gesprochen und geschrieben und diese
leute haben unter anderem handschriften
produziert wo es die kopien von
wissenschaftlichen texten einstieg
gemacht haben
die schon in der spätantike vorhanden
waren
die frühesten handschriften die wir oft
für zb platon haben sind aus dem neunten
jahrhundert zum beispiel es gibt eine
lange erklärung warum aber damit werde
ich sie nicht langweiligen lange algen
aber nochmal jetzt sollen wir an die
zeiträume gedenken platon ist also erst
schule von der heimleiter gestorben ist
alles fertig jahrhundert vor christus
und die neueste installieren die älteste
handschriften die wir für die dialogen
haben sind aus bezahlens weit mehr als
1000 jahre nachdem er gestorben ist okay
wie ist das möglich ist noch mal
erstaunlich wie kann es sein
und natürlich gibt es keine druckerei
jetzt also alles mit der hand
geschrieben sein
was das heißt es die taxi die wir lesen
können können nur existieren weil jemand
die mühe und zeit gegeben hat den ganzen
text mit der hand zu schreiben und noch
dazu muss diese kopie dann überleben
oder wieder kopiert werden also nicht in
feuer zerstört werden oder in einer
bibliothek sein wo die wikinger
plötzlich auftauchen und uns also also
kurz gesagt ist es erstaunlich dass wir
überhaupt was über antike philosophie
wissen und es ist wirklich erstaunlich
dass wir so viele platten haben und so
viel an sotschis der grund dafür ist
später antike
[Musik]
die spätantike philosophen und waren
vorwiegend plot honecker und da das
delikt und haben platon einst ort sehr
geschätzt und deswegen haben diese
deppen die haben diese texte sogar
unterrichtet info sowie kursen zum
beispiel in alexandria ägypten und
deswegen gab es viele viele kopien
dieser texte oder wenn nicht viel fehle
dann genug damit sie überlebt haben bis
in die bis an teenager r und diese
landschaften zum teil das ist dann immer
noch okay vor und diese philosophen
heißt normalerweise platonischer das
sind die nachfolger putins im dritten
jahrhundert denke schon erwähnt habe
das ist derjenige der l gibt den wagen
rom gelebt hat aber dann hab ich
geschrieben als vor spätantike gibt es
und spätantike also für philosophie
sagen wir das fängt mit dem dritten
jahrhundert nach christus an also
weiterhin schon in inside in der zeit
des römischen imperiums realistische
philosophie normalerweise betrachtet
mannheim city als flosse wie ist
zwischen hdj ließ und später antike
floss wie und neue platz muss hier gibt
es mehrere philosophische schulen vor
allem die historiker
apple korea und skeptiker die war nicht
die einzige aber die sind die hat die
drei hauptschulen die begründer dieser
stationen sind alle mehr oder weniger
zeitgenosse von aras dort ließ also die
fragen im vierten jahrhundert vor
christus an und die situation überleben
bis in die frühe spätantike
dann werden sie vernichtet und besitz
von der neuen plattform ickern
wir haben glück das plateau des ortes
durch diese zeit überlebt haben
es kann gut sein dass platon
hauptsächlich überlebt hat also seine
werke ich nicht er ist gestorben beide
aber wir haben glück dass seine werke
überlebt haben und es könnte sogar sein
dass der hauptgrund dafür ist das
eigentlich ist so schön ist also eher
waren militärisch immer sehr geschätzt
auch wenn seine philosophie nicht sehr
einflussreich war es gibt eine alte
legende dass alles dort die werke des
ortes ist fast völlig verloren gegangen
sind und dass nur eine handschrift
überlebt hat oder eine sammlung von
anschriften die dann nach rom gekommen
ist das ist wahrscheinlich entspannen
aber es ist schon der fall das nicht
sehr viele aristotelische textilien in
ungarn waren in der ersten zeit also man
könnte das so vorstellen dass platon und
aristoteles
schreiben ihre werke klattens werke sind
soweit ich weiß
gänzlich erhalten also wir haben alles
was er geschrieben hat dialogen und ein
paar dialogen dialekt geschrieben hat
was ja deswegen hab ich gesagt sobald
wir wissen ja genau
bei alles wissenwerte sicher dass wir
nicht alles haben
aber andererseits haben wir zu viel zu
lesen das ist so gut wie alles könnte
man sagen
aber im ernst also wir haben sehr viel
eines dort liest aber nicht alles was er
geschrieben hat und diese diese werke
haben das dann überlegt was gut war war
dann würden sie sehr eifrig kopiert
wurden gelesen und dann haben wir die
byzantinische tradition
das ist der grund wofür wir plattenhardt
ließ kennen zum beispiel früher lässt
sich klose wie ist es uns oft nur
indirekt oder sehr lückenhaft bekannt
zum beispiel der philosoph der meiner
meinung nach der drittgrößte oder
vielleicht viertgrößte philosoph platon
aristoteles und lud ihn in der antiken
tradition ist christ plan scheint der
beste logiker der antike außer sich
selbst
seine werke sind völlig verloren
also vielleicht fragen sie sich warum
wie kanaren-insel schätzen und logen
wenn seine werke verschwunden sind
grund ist das spätere philosophen ihn
zitieren und sonst erwähnen also sie
sagen piep hat so und so geleert oder so
und so gesagt und er hat mich recht weil
gabler zum beispiel und dann haben wir
ein so genanntes fragments von crysis
und das führt uns zurück zu den
fotografien
die physiker sind alle ausschließlich
gibt uns bekannt war spätere philosophen
sie zitieren
es gibt keine werke vor so kritiker die
sagen so frei laufen sind oder die also
es gibt keine handschriften von zum
beispiel die werke von paar männer das
was wir haben stattdessen sind spätere
texte die panne dies beschreiben also
die kaserne ideen beschreiben oder wenn
wir glück haben sogar zitieren und die
hier ist der wichtigste quelle ist ein
sehr später nimmt monika aus dem
sechsten jahrhundert nach christus ist
im krieg muss ein paar garmisch fülle es
passt der letzte fergana und vieles
offen die auf alten geschrieben hat da
haben und er hat kommentare suarez dort
ließ geschrieben
und jedes mal nicht jedes mal aber oft
wenn alles orte ließ eine postkarte
erwähnt sagt dem kiosk lieber leser
sie werden wahrscheinlich wissen wollen
was panel ist eigentlich gesagt hat weil
es in der zeit sind krieg ist es so
schwierig war texte hüppe die fonds
atticus haben und er hatte ja nicht sehr
gute bibliothek und deswegen hat er
selber in seinen kommentaren auch
kopiert ausgeschrieben und zitiert was
paar männer die es gesagt hat und
dadurch haben wir dann diese wertvolle
fragmente von
von paar männer die in andere fonds
partikel sollten dies selbst ist
ähnlicher weise eine sehr gute quelle
für vor sokratische philosophie gehabt
die zwei hauptquellen sind eigentlich
alles wirklich selbst uns im krieg aber
bei weitem nicht die einzige kennen wir
haben zitaten und fragmente und
testimonial also paraphrasierte zitaten
aus christliche philosophen aus bis ein
teenager philosophen haus plattform und
so weiter und so fort
ok also ist es heiß ist bei den vor so
kritiker das haben wir eigentlich mit
indirekte beweise oder evidenz zu tun
also dass wir haben das so ist es fast
als ob mein ist weiß wie es ist mit
archäologie aus der gleichen zeit also
wir haben diese scherben von töpfen wir
versuchen die zusammenzustellen um der
damaligen kunst zu gewinnen das ist
genauso mit den vorzug artikel was wir
absichtlich haben ist sind diese
scherben und dass deswegen also diese
dieses herrn dort plötzlich verteilt
habe mit den fragmenten oft ist das was
sie hier auf dem handy haben das ganze
fragment also es gibt keinen
zusammenhang
bis auf den text wo das fragment zitiert
wird
das ist sozusagen in tokio sagt und
deswegen sagt sie ein maximum an der das
und dann haben wir ein zitat aus einer
achse nannte wie sie sich vorstellen
können ist es ganz ganz schwierig
deswegen die ideen dieser philosophen zu
verstehen waren die ganz ganz früh also
totales xing offen ist und alles ist
nicht der einzige aus - es gibt auch die
zwei achs leute an amanda und alex sind
- und diese drei leute werden oft die
laser genannt weil sie alle aus milito
diese stadt an der küste der türkei auch
aus diesem gebiet sind ein offenes und
erste sehr bekannter name heraklit dann
als bestätigung davon was ich vorher
gesagt habe dass griechische philosophie
sozusagen überall mittelmeer rahmen
stattfindet gibt des philosophen die in
italien hohen sizilien tätig waren
die sogenannte elia tika sind aus hellem
in griechisch türkisch sprechende
italien
und hier ist der große name natürlich
paradies hatte zwei schüler namens xenon
bei uns melissas
die seine theorien dann beteiligt haben
szene und ist übrigens nichts mit der
begründer des zionismus zu verwechseln
das sehen und von lr der begründer des
sozialismus heißt sehen
von kitti haben das sage ich nur damit
sie nicht durcheinanderkommen das ist
ein problem in antike flow sowie die
haben ungefähr 30 namen und dann
verteilen sie diese zeit nahmen unter
200 leute da sein gibt es übertrieben
aber das schlimmste ist ammonium der
lehrer putins hieß harmonies und der
wichtigste kommentator in in alexandrien
die ist auch arminias und der lehrer
plutas hieß auch arminias es ist sehr
ärgerlich manchmal gibt es sogar fälle
wo wir zweifel offen
um die gleiche zeit in der im gleichen
ort haben mit dem gleichen namen
vielleicht und dann gibt es 33 ob dass
zwei leute sind oder heinz und so weiter
und so fort
und damit sind wir näher zu der zeit von
sokratis und dann und auch näher zur
technische philosophie was endlich
natürlich mit zögerliches gibt habe in
griechenland selbst gibt es dann die
andere hauptkritiker die werke von denen
würden mindestens in deutschland gelesen
leckeres es gibt eine geschichte im
final von platon rostock ots erzählt
dass er ein buch von anna kardos in
athen kaufen könnte das ist es sehr
schön sein ein sorgen
ein blick in die
tradition wie texte dann in griechenland
so gängig worden und ein paddock ist der
wollen sizilien und die vom westen
demokraten snap wir sind nicht ganz
sicher wäre
wer zuerst waren werden hierbei größter
zwischen dem abpfiff
also das ist eigentlich sechste
jahrhundert und formte jahrhundert vor
christus und dann mit und dann sorgt
dieses eigentlich auch 500 vor christus
damit werfen alles dort sind wir im
vierten jahrhundert und dann fangen
fangen die prestige edition an
ok also das ist wie gesagt zum größten
teil das was ich nicht abdecken werde in
diesem in dieser vorlesung serie was ich
hauptsächlich abdecken werde ist sind
nur platonos dort ließ aber für die
restliche zeit heute werde ich eben
diese fotografische philosophen
besprechen und in der letzten sitzung
wie gesagt werde ich werde ich einen
esstisch und spätantike dass wir sehr
schnell besprechen bevor ich jetzt
detaillierte vor sokratische flüsse wie
bespreche hat jemand fragen über die
ganze historische lage hier also das
allgemeine botschaft ist sehr lange zeit
über das ganze mittelmeer und haupt
ereignisse in athen aber es ist sony
denken an die philosophie ist das was
platon und aristoteles in athen im
vierten jahrhundert gemacht haben nein
das ist eine sehr lange tradition in
sehr kompliziert und je näher zu uns
desto besser aktuell bekannt
obwohl platini ist zum glück sehr
ausführlich erhalten sind übrigens
soweit ich weiß
der einzige philosoph aus der antike
philosophie der viel geschrieben hat wo
wir alle werke erhalten haben
platon test jemandem raten wer das ist
also wo er alles haben nicht nur viel
zum beispiel bei gallen oder augustinus
ja deswegen habe ich gesagt der einzige
der viel geschrieben hat das sollte dies
haben wir alles nämlich nichts
von also die organisation haben wir auch
nichts dass auch alles ist ja das zelt
nicht sind sie mathematiker
0 cent pro team ist die antwort also wir
haben alle die werke platins war es ein
student eine edition davon produziert
hat und dass das ist erhalten und das
ist vielleicht ein dass das bestätigt
das was ich vorher gesagt habe dass das
ist wie ein filter für uns also wir
können lesen das was sie geschätzt haben
sie haben andere platonischer geschätzt
platin alles okay ist aber herr minister
philosophen und vorsorge eigentlich
nichts und deswegen können wir platon
und aristoteles und später antike flosse
viel lesen die vor so kritiker natürlich
gebe es viel zu viel ich jetzt
diskutieren in nur 40 minuten
man könnte und aktionen vorlesungen
clubs
ja es geht schon
mensch das irgendwie
[Musik]
so
können sie das c nicht wenn ich hier
schreibe unten
na dann
benutze ich oder technische probleme
meine stiften heute okay das war aber
mindestens lustig so fangen wir mit dem
messer an und mit den hauptthemen der
statischen inklusive so wie ich vorher
kompressor gesagt habe gibt es eine
frage ob das überhaupt als philosophie
zählt meint es natürlich an sich eine
philosophische frage was philosophie ist
und was nicht und alle philosophische
fragen sind unbeantwortet
deswegen kann man nur darüber streiten
ob das was wir uns vielleicht aber man
könnte sehr gut sagen dass das
vielleicht näher zu naturwissenschaft
kommt als zu philosophie oder ich würde
lieber sagen es gibt in dieser zeit
keine strenge unterscheidung zwischen
naturwissenschaft und philosophie da
könnte man sogar weiter gehen und sagen
es gibt bis zum 18 oder 19 jahrhundert
nach christus keine strenge
unterscheidung zwischen
naturwissenschaft und philosophie wie
sie wahrscheinlich wissen hätten leute
wie zum beispiel minuten ihre aufgabe
als naturoase wie beschrieben also
naturphilosophie
die erforschung der natur war das ganz
ganz spät in der geschichte einfach ein
unterteil der philosophie und deswegen
haben diese spätere leute keine bedenken
zu sagen dass die forscher philosophie
in zeiten wo es ist aber vielleicht
etwas schwieriger und manche thesen die
bei den frostigen auftauchen sind sehr
offensichtlich philosophische themen zum
beispiel oder prothesen zum beispiel bei
paar männer des mannes muss so
offensichtlich eine philosophie theorie
dass verdi bald bescheiden aber das was
die vorsicht was andere vor südafrika
und auf bali selbst manchmal gemacht
haben
das ist mehr wie ein versuch natürliche
erklärungen zu finden für natürliche
phänomene zum beispiel sagen sie so was
wie was ist ein regenbogen es ist nur
eine wolke wohl nicht durchscheint oder
sowas
was ist dann die andere möglichkeit also
wenn man zb einen regenbogen erklären
will ohne so was zu sagen was könnte man
sagen oder was hätten die griechen
gesagt
natürlich könnte man sagen dass der
regenbogen irgend etwas göttliches erst
und das haben sie sogar gesagt dass es
gab eine göttin des regenbogens oder
anderes beispiel was sehr naheliegend
ist was es donner oder was ist blitz das
ist laut es dort ließ wenn vorher in
einer wolke dann plötzlich erlöst wird
band andere leute die meisten leute
hätten gesagt das ist so als der ärger
hat oder so was
und das ist sehr oberflächlich aber
irgendwie richtig dass die die frühe
prosa kritiker ihre ambition war
religiöse erklärungen mit
wissenschaftlichen erklärungen sie über
zu ersetzen
das ist sehr grob und viel für den
mehreren hinsichten aber es ist ein
guter anfangspunkt und deswegen sehen
wir dass sie sehr viel interesse daran
haben
natur sehr genau zu beobachten und mit
allen mitteln die zur verfügung stehen
zu analysieren hier ist schon ein gutes
beispiel tal es also wir haben
eigentlich zwei fragmente von ihm oder
testimonial was er wirklich gesagt hat
aber bevor ich dazu komme kann ich
erwähnen dass er anscheinend ein guter
wissenschaftler war zum beispiel also
das berühmteste was er gemacht hat ist
ein finsternis vorhergesehen
wenn das heißt dass er sich sehr gut mit
astronomie ausgekannt hat ist das
plausibel können wir uns fragen antwort
definitiv weil schon in babylonien und
ägypten waren sie der mathematik und
astronomie sehr fortgeschritten und es
gibt theorien wie mathematische lehre
aus ägypten oder noch weiter von osten
in die griechische sprache eingewandert
haben könnte es gibt übrigens immer
wieder die frage also dass fast die
frage die ich am häufigsten gefragt
werde ist ob praktische philosophie oder
wissenschaft irgendwas mit indien zu tun
haben könnte
das passt sicherlich zufügen dafür aber
schon bei zeitgenossen von des ortes
haben wir
philosophen wo die antike leute selbst
behauptet haben dass sie irgendwelche
verbindung so indische lehre hatten
nicht vergessen dass alexander größe
ganz nach nach indien gekommen ist mit
seinem armee und dann gibt es die
vermutung vielleicht sind ideen zusammen
zurück gewandert
weil es alles sehr vage und schwer
festzustellen es gibt ähnliche denen
über platinen zum beispiel aber ich
ehrlich gesagt habe ich nie wirklich
beweise gesehen für indisches einfluss
auf griechische philosophie habe das ist
nicht unmöglich sagen wir das so auf
jeden fall zurück totale ist er war ein
guter mathematiker mein lieblingsteil
ist geschichte ist über die oliven mit
seinem kenntnis über naturphilosophie
kann jemand diese geschichte schon
wollen sie das erzählen das ist
wahrscheinlich ein lustiger in
muttersprache deutsche des saales
ja genau also wie digitales reich
geworden ist also hat im voraus gewusst
dass die liefen sehr gut wachsen im
kommenden jahr war der zweite beobachtet
hat und dann hat er also die geschichte
die ich kenne ist dass er halt die
pressen die oliven prassen heißen die
klassen ja die oliven prassen gekauft
und hatte praktisch ein monopol auf
olivenöl für dieses jahr
schön oder also erste erste erste
philosoph und erste kapitalistisch aber
wenn er nur die solche sachen gemacht
hätte würden wir ihn vielleicht nicht
als philosoph eindeutig und war auch
zwei sachen gesagt die wirklich sehr
philosophisch klängen einst ist hat ja
es nicht klar was er gesagt hat
irgendwas mit wasser also hatte
irgendwie einen dingen für wasser der
hat nichts ein ding verfasser ist unter
meinen lieblings gedenken wasser das sie
auch so ich würde sagen sechsten platz
wahrscheinlich einen guten und also wenn
man alles orte ließ glaubt dachte er
dass alles auf wasser schwimmt ist
vielleicht dass die welt ist wie sein
das was auf wasser schwimmt vielleicht
andere möglichkeit ist dass er gelernt
hat dass alles aus wasser besteht und so
ein gedanke kommt immer wieder vor bei
den anderen vor so kritiker also haben
ein maximum an da hat ein prinzip das
nennt der sogenannte empire und annex i
- lehrt dass alles aus luft kommt jeder
kriegt das alles aus feuer kommt und das
macht es sehr gern
er ist sagt an dass es sagt immer die
vorsichtige wurden alles auf ein element
reduzieren
zum beispiel thale ist wasser heraklit
feuer und dann will er irgendwie
irgendwas dadurch beweisen also zum
beispiel dass alle seine vorgänger sich
nur materielle ursachen interessiert
haben
das ist sehr gefährlich meint nicht
wasser was er kann auch gefährlich sein
aber das wirklich ist einfach ernst zu
nehmen oder einfach oberflächlich zu
lesen und dann sagen okay dass es fast
alles gelehrt hat dass es da muss man
vorsichtig haben weil das ist es fast
immer die vorsorge erwähnt und zitiert
um irgendeinen philosophischen punkte zu
machen das was ihn interessiert also
hier geht es um zum beispiel materie
ihre ursache und das heißt nicht
unbedingt dass er fair oder anna kratz
die lehre der frostige beschreibt aber
es ist trotzdem auffällig dass so viele
von diesen postkarten alles auf einen
prinzip zurück geführt haben
ich habe ein zitat darüber bei für
thales er sagt das wasser sei prinzip
deshalb weshalb auch erklärte die erde
sei auf dem wasser also erde schwimmt
auf wasser angeblich wahrscheinlich
begründete er diese annahme damit dass
er beobachtet die nahrung aller
lebewesen sei feucht und das sieht man
schon das problem dass ist als ort ist
glaube ich das sieht man das problem
einerseits bringt es also personell
alles besteht aus wasser also unsere
körper bestehen aus wasser weil wir
feuchtes essen mit leuten essen ernährt
werden
andererseits sagte alle schwimmt aus
wasser diese zwei sachen müssen nicht
unbedingt miteinander zu tun haben
vielleicht doch also vielleicht hat er
gedacht okay wir fangen mit wasser an
und dann wird was ja irgendwie dichte
und kondensiert und das was etwas dicht
wird ist erde und das stimmt im wasser
und dann ist besteht alles aus wasser
aber belege dafür haben wir nicht also
ich meine das ist buchstäblich das was
wir haben
sie haben die information alle
informationen über teile ist das wasser
lehrer die zu haben es fast okay das ist
ein dem was er gesagt hat es andere
dinge ist folgendes nach der
überlieferung zu erteilen hat es den
anschein dass portal ist die seele aus
bewegungs ursache betrachtet hat er
behauptete jedenfalls der magnet stein
habe weil er das eisen bewegte eine
seele so schön oder also magnet stein
muss eine seele haben muss lebend sein
vielleicht weil es eisen ansehen kann
und hier haben wir möglicherweise eine
ganz interessante theorie eine
philosophische theorien bevor ich jetzt
spekulieren was das sein könnte nicht zu
überschauen hier ist das ist als alles
dort ließ sagt nach der überlieferung zu
verteilen also selbst alles dort ließ
ist es ihm selbst sehr unklar
fast alles sagen wollte und das kann gut
sein weil teile ist es schon 200 jahre
vorher sollten ist mit dem trikots die
die nennen diese leute oft die antike
philosophen also die antike philosophen
einen default express adresse kritiker
die alten leute die antiken ok posten
was
könntet alle ist hier sagen wollen
unklar
aber vielleicht wollte ja sagen bahn
seele ist ein prinzip der bewegung und
daraus kann man sehen dass selbst ein
magnet stein eine seele haben muss weil
ein magnet stein bewegung verursachen
kann wenn das die theorie ist ist das
wirklich sehr beeindruckend
mindestens weil es dort ließ dann später
auch die zelle als ein prinzip der
bewegung definiert unter anderem also da
ist alles sozusagen 200 jahre im voraus
leider wissen wir wieder nichts mehr als
das was man trotzdem sagen kann ist das
tal ist so typisch vor so kratzig ist in
dem er versucht natürliche erklärungen
zu finden für kompliziertere phänomene
und maximale und angst sind ähnlich also
wie gesagt haben behauptet dass er heute
nach ex ministers alles haus luft
besteht also nur meine fragments kleine
fragmente vorzulesen
ein ex minister als prinzip der seien
die dinge die luft an
denn als dieser entstehe alles und diese
löst sich alles wieder auf die incity
seele behauptete die luft ist von uns
durch ihre kraft zusammenhält so umfasst
auch den ganzen kosmos atem und luft
zweiten examen ist behauptete gott sei
luft und er entstehe und seien
unermesslich unendlich und hebel in
bewegung
diese idee der unendlichkeit kommt auf
bei seiner sei genossen auch als magnet
vor maxime under
er ist wahrscheinlich etwas früher als
eine aktie - übrigens ich liebe diesen
namen kann also wenn sie es wenn jemand
hier schwanger ist oder eine schwangere
partnerin hat wahrscheinlich haben sie
keinen schwangen partner
aber wenn dann bitte wir sagen ja das
will ich mit einem sehr guten namen
sucht für das kommende kennt annex i -
warum nicht
ich finde das passt auch für ein mädchen
oder sagen wir das passt genauso gut für
ein mädchen okay aber ein aktienanteil
saatgut ein akzente flex villingen achse
man den ex minister
maxi mini ist ein maximaler essen
ich habe meine kinder ist leider schon
anders genannt
maxi mann der aus miliz sackt das
prinzip der seinen dinge sei das
unendliche tor ab heran also das was
keine grenze halt tor ab herum denn aus
diesem entstehe alles und zu diesem
budget alles weshalb auch unendlich
viele bellten produziert werden und
wieder vergehen zu jenem aus dem sie
entstehen
er gibt auch den gründen weshalb des
halbes unendliches damit das praktische
entstehen keine in sich nachlasse und
dann sagte auch als welchen dingen die
seine dinge ihr entstehen haben in diese
findet auch ihr vergehen statt wie es
sein muss denn sie leisten einen direkt
und strafe für das unrecht gemäß der
zeitlich in ordnung
also ich möchte ich jetzt nur zwei
themen betonen erstens dieses versuch
ein prinzip zu finden
das wie gesagt das könnte gefährlich
sein also man sieht sogar wie englisch
die formulierungen sind in den
fragmenten von maximal in einer extremen
ist das heißt es wirklich geht durch die
vorträge und sagt uns was sie alle für
ein prinzip genannt haben
ob sie wirklich in dieser diese dieses
prinzip spiel spielen wollten ist unklar
aber gibt es auf jeden fall sehr stark
den eindruck dass sie alles also die
ganze welt erklären wollten dadurch dass
sie einen prinzip identifizieren
sie waren nicht einig was also manchmal
ist luft manchmal was manchmal ab heron
das unbestimmte oder unbegrenzt
oder was auch immer das heißen soll also
das was keine grenze oder definition hat
das ist auf jeden fall ein thema und ich
finde immer gemeinde das könnte
vielleicht nie vorkommen
aber ich finde es eigentlich nicht so
schlecht also wenn wir daran denken was
ist es dass wir von wissenschaft
erwarten ist sogar heutzutage wir
erwarten dass sie eine eine breite
anzahl von phänomene durch irgendwelche
prinzipien oder theorien erklären zum
beispiel sie sagen okay es gibt all
diese sachen in der welt um uns herum
die bestehen alle aus atomen euro
dankeschön
also eine das ist ein mächtiger eine
sehr märkte erklärung eine erklärung die
natürlich schon in der antike vorhanden
war und man immer wenn wir das anschauen
wahrscheinlich war ich gott sei dank
aber dass die atheisten vorgeschlagen
haben war eigentlich nur die neueste
fassung diese alte idee dass wir wollen
alles aus einem prinzip erklären und
warum dass wir es noch sagen wollen dass
alles aus irgendwas besteht
wahrscheinlich dadurch dass dieses
urstoff immer andere was anderes wird
und hin und her geht also zum beispiel
67 ist gott gott sei luft und er
entstehe und sein hohes league unendlich
und ewigen bewegung also es irgendwie
erklärt warum
bewegung oder veränderungen in der welt
haben und sehr interessant ist maximal
dieses fragments ist übrigens
wahrscheinlich die erste zitat das
postquartier sowie also keine paraphrase
ist sondern wirklich ein zitat das bei
simply qos aus welchen dingen die seien
die dinge dinge entstehen haben in diese
findet auch ihr vergehen statt wie es
sein muss denn sie leisten einander
recht und strafe für das unrecht gemäß
der zeitlichen ordnung
darüber könnte man eine ganze stunde
sprechen über diesen satz aber eine idee
dahinter ist mindestens das eine ein
ding wird ein anderes ding also entsteht
und sein wird dann zerstückelt zerstört
zum beispiel menschen entstehen und dann
sterben und gehen zurück in ihre
ursprüngliche zutaten so sagen später
bei empedokles werden die zutaten die
uhr zutaten die vier elemente die wir
kennen
was also meint das ist das erste was uns
wahrlich ein fels in der antiken physik
das sind natürlich die elemente die dann
wieder bei platon hatte sotschis
vorkommen vorher eher der luft und
wasser aber für diese posse gattiker die
dachten ein wird das können wir alles
erreichen mit einem element so sagen
also zum beispiel luft ist das
bewegliche was es gibt vielleicht heute
gedacht und die haben auch immer
menschen als beispiele genommen also was
ist das prinzip was buch was uns am
leben hält teile sagte wasser weil wir
durch nasses ernährt werden und bier und
alle tiere aber maxi maxi minister
gesagt luft vielleicht weil wir immer
wieder atmen müssen um weiterzuleben
und dadurch haben sie sind sie auf diese
theorie gekommen sie können alles auf
einen prinzip zurückführen
und noch besser dachten sie es gibt eine
gegenseitige hin und her bewegung oder
veränderung und deswegen haben wir diese
sehr interessante zitat sie leisten
einander recht und strafe für das
uhrwerk gemäss derzeitig in ordnung dhzb
denn vorher gelöscht wird und wird luft
dann muss luft irgendwann wieder feuer
werden und umgekehrt
also alles muss so hin und herbewegt
werden oder verändert werden und dieses
hin und her kommt vor allem bei heraklit
vor sind offen ist also ich werde
vielleicht nur kurz harrten der scanner
offen ist sehr gut dieses thema
schildert dass die euro-kritiker
religiöse gedanken mit wissensfragen
gedanken ersetzen wollte was ich vorher
gesagt habe
er ist der erste fotografie soweit wir
kennen der die traditionelle religiöse
glauben kritisiert hat das berühmteste
ist er gesagt hat wenn löwen die harry
potter hätten würden sie diese gottes
löwen vorstellen
wir fühlen uns irgendein anderes anders
die vielleicht sogar auf dem herd
wenn die rinder und pferde und löwen
hände hätten nun mit diesen händen
morgen konnten und bildwerke schaffen
wie menschen so würden die pferde die
götter abbilden und malen der gestaltung
werden die rente in der von rindern
sie würden solche statuen meißeln ihre
eigenen körper gstaad entsprechen also
hier macht der sich lustig über menschen
die götter aus menschen vorstellen
übrigens ist es nicht der fall dass
diese fonds kritiker nicht religiös
waren oder nicht an gott geglaubt haben
was sind auch sein ob es eigentlich
sagen wollte ist dass dort doch
existiert aber dass diese dass menschen
dort falsch verstehen
er hatte anscheinend nur einen gott weil
er sagte ein einzige gott ist unter
göttern und menschen der größte
vielleicht heißt das es gibt andere gute
die kleiner sind natürlich so groß sind
weder dem körper noch der einsicht nach
der sterblichen menschen gleich also er
wollte sagen dass es wieder ein zitat
er wollte sagen gott ist was besser als
menschen nicht nur ein sehr mächtiger
mensch okay aber zu wirkst du dieses hin
und her bewegung veränderungen
geschichte jetzt kommen wir zu herder
klietz und heraklit ist vor allem dafür
bekannt dass er behauptet hat alles sei
ständig in bewegung
es ist so genannte flics theorie dass
alles fließt und das bekannteste hier
ist sein berühmtes fragments was in
mehreren versionen überliefert wird
wo ist das hab ich das nicht auf dem hab
ich mir mal auf dem 100 komisch weil sie
das fragment habe das kennen sie
wahrscheinlich dass das mit dass mit dem
fluss man kann nicht zwei mal in einen
fluss einsteigen
es gibt wie gesagt verschiedene
versionen
erst die version also eine buchstäbliche
version werde über diejenige die in den
gleichen fluss steigen ließen andere und
andere besser
das ist eine sehr wirkliche übersetzung
als thema kritisch was könnt ihr das
heißen platten hatte eine idee was das
heißen könnte er dachte hat der klub
wollte sagen so was wie realität ist wie
ein fluss alles verändert sich ständig
alles ist immer in bewegung
das ist eine sehr berühmte und beliebte
idee die man mit heraklit verbindet
manchmal sagen leute aber es kommt wie
buddhismus oder was auch immer
die grundlegende idee daher der krieg
werde
ständige bewegung das ist völlig falsch
leider das ist eine fehlinterpretation
vielleicht sogar absichtlich falsche
auslegung von heraklit die wir bei
platon finden wobei es könnte es sehr
gut sein dass zeitgenossen von platon
doch diese ständige bewegung idee hatten
weil platon erwähnt solche leute zum
beispiel partie los übrigens haben sie
den heute die erste seite der erst zeit
gesehen
sie kennen sie wie also in der ersten
gibt es immer dieses streiflicht ja oben
links das fängt mit einem paragraf über
kraton kraton an
auf jeden fall ratlos der hauptfigur
dieses dialoges er war ein so ein
händler
wer dachte dass alles den linken
bewegung ist also die hdj ließ sackers
hat gesagt man kann nicht gesagt man
kann nicht einen einfluss sogar einmal
einsteigen weil der fluss existiert
nicht weil er ständig in bewegung ist
nichts existiert
es gibt keine einheitliche dinge es gibt
nur bewegung
okay das war es sehr unwahrscheinlich
die grundlegende lehre des era kids viel
mehr was er sagen wollte war ähnlicher
zu dem was wir schon bei den laser
gesehen haben nämlich dass wir eine
gegenseitige wirkung von verschiedene
sachen in der natur haben und vielleicht
gibt es dann ein ei nur prinzip was
hinter dieser ständigen kreisförmigen
bewegungen gibt
das wäre verriet feuer war vorher ein
schnell bewegende dynamische ursache
sein könnte anscheinend und das
besondere an heraklit ist das sehr
also erstens haben wir sehr viele
zitaten von heraklit und das ist
deswegen weil er sich so ausdrucksvoll
der mann ausgedrückt hat er hat
wahrscheinlich keinen kein buch
geschrieben im sinne von ein buch wo er
argumentiert er ihn darstellt er hat
diese sprüche erfunden und dies sind
fast wie rätseln in der es hieß sogar
der wrestler ist das ein gehört rösler
wird jemand der immer rätseln erzählt
ich habe es gerade davon
er ist der dritte in der antike weil er
immer die mit diesen mit diesen sprüchen
hell gekommen ist und wie wir ihn immer
sage das schöne an heraklit ist der hat
sogar in fragmenten geschrieben
also ist der ultimative posser kritiker
also hat zu einzelne sätze formuliert
ihm gesagt habe das ist meine lehre zum
beispiel das mit dem fluss oder das ist
schon alles ist austauschbar gegen feuer
und feuer gegen alles wie waren gegen
gold und gold gegen waren
das ist eine so dicke rische fassung von
dem was wir schon gesehen haben also es
gibt diese stoffe die werden andere
stoffe und dann kommen zurück
also alles ist vorher wie rita
vielleicht aus einem grund und wird luft
und duft wird dann wasser wasser wird
ein herr das ist eigentlich nicht so
fördert meinen wenn sie daran denken
okay wenn sie was verbrennen das geht in
die luft
sogar aufgeschaltet es geht in kraft
und dann kommt zurück als regen das ist
wasser und dann geht das in die erde ein
also dieses diese kreis vor wg bewegung
ist sehr naheliegend und ist man könnte
es vielleicht sogar vermuten die fangen
irgendwo alle in dieser bewegung anläuft
vorher was auch immer aber ich denke
dass das heraklit diese idee dann weiter
geführt hat und ihn eine sehr abstrakte
richtung genommen hat oder geführt hat
nämlich wollte er sagen dass dieses den
domain nur ein beispiel ist von was dass
wir überall in der welt in der natur
finden nämlich an die sogenannte
residence der entgegengesetzten das
zusammen gekommen dass der
entgegengesetzten alles alles ist
irgendwie ins seinem gegensatz
eingeschlossen oder hat seine ursprünge
in seinem gegensatz
hier ist das beste beispiel cluster
beispiel vielleicht dieser spruch der
weg hinauf und hinab ist ein und
derselbe tief der weg hinauf
es klingt wie was das man auch ein t
shirt schreiben könnte und was er sagen
will es gibt nur einen weg und es geht
rauf und runter dass das ist ein
beispiel von dem was er sagen will
die entgegengesetzte eigenschaften in
der welt kommen immer zusammen
das ist was er es allen leuten auf teile
diesen punkt mit wortspiele gemacht mein
lieblingsbeispiel ist bios zu tun als
und bios 1 hätte das ist jetzt alles
wird so geschrieben so oder so aber ein
wort heißt bogen wie schießbuden von das
andere heißt leben
deswegen sagt er der name des bogens
bios ist leben bios seine tat der tod
also das bringt sachen um obwohl es
leben heißt es die content repository
die konsistenz der entgegengesetzten und
das ist irgendwie eine grundlegende
theorie womit er angeblich alles
erklären kann was nicht sehr gut zu dem
was ich schon gesagt habe passt ist sein
hauptsegment vielleicht also nicht dass
mit dem fluss sondern ein fragment und
wo wir erfahren dass das ein anfang
eines buches war von ihm und hier sagt
er gegenüber der hier gegebenen und
unabänderlich gültigen auslegung
erweisen sich die menschen also
verständnislos sowohl bevor sie als wenn
sie einmal gehört haben
das klingt in der tat die ein anfang
eines buches aber so weit wie wir wissen
hat er kein buch gehabt sondern nur all
diese sprüche aber vielleicht war es ein
buch sei es ist für mich schon an und
dann kamen alle widersprüche ist klar
aber haben die diese erwähnung eines
logos eine auslegung
erklärungen oder begründung oder
erzählung das ist ein schritt des wortes
schwieriges übersetzen dass die der
logos denn er begreifen wollte was nun
dachte fast niemanden versteht ist
vielleicht nur herr besteht dass der
logos ist wahrscheinlich genau das dass
die das entgegengesetzte sachen
zusammenkommen
das heißt dieser spruch mit dem fluss
hat einen ganz anderen punkt das ist
nicht fern dass alle ständig in bewegung
ist dass wir wieder ein beispiel also
einfluss immer wieder neue wasser über
diejenige die in einen einfluss
einsteigen fließen immer neue und neue
wasser gewässer
das ist nur wieder ein beispiel es ist
derselbe in einer hinsicht aber an dass
in einer anderen hinsicht genau wie ein
weg der hinauf geht und auch hinab diese
idee das alles eins erst irgendwie dass
die die die entgegengesetzte sachen der
natur irgendwie eine einheit bilden wird
dann so der ultimativen folge geführt
von paramente ist so genannte vater der
mitte für sieg beim energy haben wir
wirklich glück weil das ist wirklich ein
fall wo ein simples wo die unbedingt
dass leute die ein ähnliches lesen
konnte und in seinem kommentar zu
dort ließ er transkribiert fast die
ganze also ein gedicht von paar männern
soll der gedicht vom parlament ist wo er
seine flosse wie entfaltet hat
allerdings das paradies ein sehr
komplizierter philosophie dieses gedicht
hat sie erscheinen zwei hälften die hat
er die althea genannt und dogs also die
die wahrheit und die meinung
oft werden sie der weg der
wahrheit genannt und wägt der meinung
die weg der weg der meinung ist wieder
so eine kosmologische theorie wo er zwei
prinzipien hat nämlich licht und nacht
und die kommen zusammen und gestalten
ein welt eine welt das hat sind videos
nur teilweise zitiert aber sehr
ausführlich zitiert er den weg der
wahrheit wo er überhaupt nicht diese
kosmologische theorie beschreibt sondern
muñiz muss und ein grundlegendes problem
im parlament dieses auslegung ist zu
erklären was diese zwei hälften zu tun
mit dem lande zu tun haben also wahrheit
und doxa meinung was sie miteinander zu
tun haben ist sehr schwer zu sagen da
ich werde das wir werden nicht versuchen
das jetzt zu erklären werden nur den weg
der wahrheit' kurz beschreiben
der grund wofür er hofft der so der
vater der mitte physik genannt wird ist
das der weg der wahrheit wirklich eine
ununterbrochene kette von argumente
anbietet also der erste der aus der
wirklich argumente für die logische
argumente anbietet um eine philosophie
these zu begründen
also keine rätsel harte sprüche keine
feststellungen die vielleicht eine
philosophische erklärung dahinter haben
wie bei thal ist sondern wirklich
argumente und sein hauptargument ist
dass das nicht sein und sauber und
undenkbar ist weil es ist nichts was ist
eigentlich naheliegend ist und dann sagt
er dass wenn man nicht sein ausschließt
dass man
keine veränderung akzeptieren kann und
sogar keine unterscheidung weil
unterscheiden heißt also sie sind von
mir anders sie sind nicht nicht
deswegen haben wir beide nicht sein
relativ so einander aber es gibt keinen
nicht sein
deswegen sind wir nicht anders das ist
nervig ist ein argument kommt nicht vor
wie ein super argument natürlich aber es
hat schon was
wie wir sehen werden haben platon und
aristoteles sehr viele schwierigkeiten
zu erklären wie nichts sein in einer
mathe physik eingebaut werden kann ohne
zu akzeptieren das nicht sein irgendwie
existiert was absurd klingt
und um das zu vermeiden hat paradies
sein argumentiert das alles eins ist und
dass alles nun veränderlich ist dieses
sogenannte moniz muss also es gibt und
wie gesagt dass es komisch dass er dann
in der regel der meinung in der in dem
weg der meinung dann sagt es gibt zwei
prinzipien und die kombinieren haben es
könnte zum beispiel sein dass das die
zweitbeste erklärungen ist aber die
beste erklärung wäre man es muss ist
unklar
aber was danach passiert ist das andere
philosophen gekommen sind die dann
versuchen diese these ist zu
unterstützen mit neue argumente
ministers wäre ich nicht beschreiben
arbeit zenon ist er ist jetzt die zeit
wert weil er diese super paradoxen hat
die sie wahrscheinlich schon kennen
zum beispiel seien die chemie paradox
nichts kann also er will zeigen dass die
panel ist behauptet hat dass nichts sich
bewegen kann und das beweist der
folgendermaßen versagt
das was bewegen müsste also nehmen wir
eigentlich geht von hier ist zum fenster
um das zu tun musste ich zuerst die
halbe strecke schaffen
ja also auf dem weg zum fenster sieht
die halbe strecke schaffen
aber um das zu tun muss sich die hälfte
der halben strecke schaffen
aber um das zu tun die hälfte der halben
strecke und so weiter und das kann man
immer zurückführen und das argument ist
dann ein bisschen unklar
aber vielleicht wahrscheinlich was ja
gemeint hat ist ich muss eine unendliche
anzahl von aufgaben erfüllen um das
fenster zu erreichen weil ich muss die
die hälfte des viertels das dritte und
so weiter und so weiter und so fort und
es gibt eine unendliche kette hier
niemand kann eine unendliche anzahl von
sachen schön
deswegen gibt es keine bewegung h
das deutlich erwähnt dass und hat eine
lösung dafür vielleicht fände es wird es
später besprechen
ein extra die krise werde ich später
besprechen weil sie kommen dann die sind
wichtig für platon und aristoteles ich
werde die gleich die gelegenheit haben
die beiden aber an die also kurz was sie
vielleicht lieber ein extra das wissen
sollen ist dass er die meinung vertrat
dass alles mit allem vermischt er ist
also in jedem körper sind alle anderen
arten von körpern und das hätte hat er
vielleicht dass es vielleicht dazu
gekommen ähnlich wie diese frühere vor
so kritiker mit wasser läuft er hat an
unsere körper die den menschlichen fall
gedacht und gedacht wie kann es sein
dass wir nicht brot hesse dass ich
daraus fleisch produzieren wie kann es
sein dass mein fleisch irgendwie
erneuert wird dadurch dass ich prozesse
wahrscheinlich weil das fleisch in dem
brot gibt also tut mir leid vegetarier
vegetarier
so haben diese ganze zeit was
verschwenderisch gemacht fleisch ist
überall
jetzt werden wir es nicht vermeiden und
im paddock es ist der vater der lehre
der vier elemente in paris hat übrigens
auch eine sehr schön er ist ein sehr
schönes beispiel wo alles durch eine
kreisbewegung aus allen produziert wird
also er lehrt das alles wahrscheinlich
zusammen war als eine homogene ist werde
es mehr oder weniger wie parlament ist
mit seinem sein meint seinem 11
aber dann wird es geteilt in die vier
elemente und die werden dann tiere in
einer art und weise die wir später bei
der stadt lesen werden und nur zum
schluss die atheisten
ich habe jetzt drei minuten für die alte
müssten die atheisten ist also das
naheliegendste wie wir die atheisten zu
sagen ist die hatten diese tolle idee
ein bisschen wie zentrum von l e wir
können alles aufteilen und wenn wir
teilen und teilen teilen teilen dann
kommen wir auf unendlich kleine teile
und das irgendwie unvernünftige deswegen
musste es irgendwo aufhören
und da wo wir aufhören sind die atome
atome heißt dass das was man mit
schneiden kann also kommen heißt
schneiden
häufig ist übrigens die die größe der
atome sind ganz schlechte atomen weil
man sie teilen kann
also falsch wissen keine atome sind nur
klein aber die sind wirklich atomen die
kommen in verschiedene gestalte und
größen und kombinieren um größere körper
zu bauen zum beispiel unsere körper man
könnte denken das kommt aus heiterem
himmel wie sind sie darauf gekommen aber
eine gute gedanke werde dass das auch
wie die npd es eine reaktion auf paar
männer dies ist paradies hat
ausgeschlossen dass das nicht sein die
irgendeine rolle in unsere mitte physik
spielen kann und die atom westen haben
gesagt doch es gibt das nicht sein
das ist was sie lehren genannt haben
also lehre ist so ein zusammenhang wo
die atome dann stattfinden kann oder was
bewegen können und es gibt deswegen in
einer theorie design.de die atomen und
es nicht sein die das leere und mit
diesen beiden prinzipien können sie dann
alles erklären genau wie die großartige
machen wollten
und hier also ich finde die atom mit
atom ist sehr schön und so fernen
kulturen station für vor sokratische
sophie weil einerseits gehen sie zurück
sie diese ganz frühe leute und sagen wir
haben eine stoffliche erklärung für
alles das in der welt existiert aber
andererseits das ist ganz nette physisch
also es gegen daraus dass wir sehen dass
luft wasser wird oder sowas beträgen ist
es sehr abstrakt also sie denken sie
sitzen sie setzen sich sozusagen hin
machen die augen zu und denken wie
können wir dieses problem mit sein und
nichtsein lösen
die kommen auch artemis muss
wahrscheinlich auf als gegenwert sonst
diese diese teilen
argumente die bei den allergiker
vorgekommen sind
also ist irgendwie dass das was man was
erwarten könnte als hände der
erfolgskritischen internation dringende
fragen gut also wir sehen uns nächste
woche und dann werde ich kurz zu
kritisch besprochen und dann werden wir
anfangen uns zu gestalten